servette actualise croyez qu'on devienne
son butin mère trop polis fort rebond
seront pas les super héros sont hors la
loi on veut faire la bagarre y revient
la sentence est irrévocable veut pas
dire que tu quoi ouais j'ai entendu ça à
la télé ce millionnaire voudrait qu'on
le rencontre il ya un truc de super
héros dans l'air il est temps pour les
super de reprendre du service
il nous faut hélas stickers au revoir
gérer
occupent d enfants est inquiète pas non
c'est pas comme ça que le propose a dit
faire pourquoi il veut qu'on fasse comme
ça mais je sais pas faire comme ça
pourquoi ils veulent changer les maths
les bats et les maths on ne change pas
les battre partout dans nos villes et
d'odeurs s'endorment on s endort le
réveil il sombre lol sommeil je serais
pas arrivé s'il comptait pas pris le
relais il faut que je réussisse pour
qu'elle réussisse
digard
s'ils restent devant que les sétois
c'est flippant mais je ne veux pas le
nourrir
[Musique]
bien élever un enfant est un acte
héroïque
c'est tout un art il ya l'art et la
manière